well shooting school I am I'm a little
revved up right now first your first day
on set it's much shooting your show it's
my first day on set what I like about
working with with the crew people when
you when you work on big sets with
people who've been working on [ __ ]
forever
they can do anything anytime today the
last shot I had I'm in a golf cart this
big golf cart and you know his white
shirt is really blowing his face out so
we we got a we got to do something and
one of the guys goes well why don't we
just lose the top and all right
because what do you want to do this will
just cut the top can we cut the top off
I go of the cart it's made of steel may
Colin and the guy who literally goes
like this the guy goes let's get a
sawzall in here please I turn around
grab a cup of coffee and it's the top is
off they saw Prague well-oiled machine
right now what do you need right now
hang a unicorn you want a flock of geese
real ones to run into that plane of
glass and die all at the same time we
can do that - give me a half hour I find
it fascinating amazing just my short
experience on the set I'd love to come
on yours oh you got it there's someone
on there and it's lines me of football
there's the offense coordinator defense
corner that figure out everything they
know every moving part camera angle
shock on do continuity continuity oh by
the way your feet your hand you had that
you you were you were putting the pin in
this way your your thumb was pointed
down so make sure you pointed - how do
you keep track of that which did I turn
left or right on the last egg left no I
had a crush on well they got like this
older Silver Fox yeah they're like he's
worked on Deadpool Jurassic Park he's
done everything and you know he's just
here to put to help out and hewed oh no
no so on camera when he went groaning
you see the faith he's going through it
I'm like dang oh yeah such a boss yes
yes well those who's been doing it for
you forever that might have been the DP
Susan the director of photography yeah
so he's got to see he sets up the shots
he sees all the lighting all the
lighting in his team it's such a
well-oiled machine they'll do and we
gotta get a flag over here I need a
thing I just it just happens it's too
deep for me going on sir
coming on your set it would be like
someone that has no clue about the NFL
and then just being on the Denver
Broncos sideline buddy well yeah well
can you honimaru 42 XYZ right let watch
you tackle watch the line back in and
you're like tomorrow to come try to come
okay maybe it's kind of now I feel
pressured you got to come I know I want
to yeah they all want to meet you too
everybody knows yeah you know oh you are
were you nervous at all you for it I
mean you've been done a lot of sit don't
get you don't get nervous not even a
little I've been playing this character
for four years you know you're doing but
there's a lot more riding on the slot on
this right now the one thing I never
worry about is nerves I just do my job I
know what ideal you know I'm saying like
it's a big like well the biggest
opportunity of your career once you say
like your own show yeah show before you
know which one fat actress inside
Schwartz I mean I've had my own but it
wasn't like like now it's you right but
at the same thing I see what you're
saying I mean you know I was feet I was
a series regular yeah but now yeah but
now you're older like you know it yeah
yeah well you been there why because
because this show shoots seven minutes
away from the podcast that's why because
it's seven minutes away from my home
yeah I mean you know what it means
everything is so it's so perfect
I want this show the last 10 years
that'd be nice I hope it does because
when you get on set also it's like high
school everybody's excellent their job
that's the other thing is you're in the
Union in Los Angeles if you climb out
sag oh my or you're in order to sag just
sag actors are one thing that's an
Actors Guild when you are somebody who
works on the crew who makes [ __ ] happens
from the driver to the gaffer to whoever
it is to the prop master the guy who
gives you the props those people are the
best at the game there they are so
professional they ready
they never [ __ ] up they never [ __ ] up
because if you because with all that
money online if you don't have the watch
on the actor they have no office knows
ASEA you kid there are no there are no
errors you cannot have an error you
cannot have you cannot have when the
guys pulling focused you know what that
is so as you're moving the camera okay
as you're moving the camera listen this
pressure
you're moving the camera you've got to
keep he's dialing the camera he's got to
keep that focus on your face the whole
time if you if the actors are doing a
very heavy scene and you screw that
focus up and they go we got to do it
again the actors like what that's the
best thing like okay then we got to do
it again they go who's [ __ ] up it's
the focus puller that guy's not he's not
doing this well and I'm here tomorrow
you're gone yeah you're not there to
your god yeah we cannot find another guy
to do it yeah cuz you're making Bryan
Callen or Shia LaBeouf do it over and
over can you don't like no but it's also
costing money it's costing my name
because cuz you have a location you
can't you can't rep we were shooting in
high school you can't rent the high
school I level stuff very hot so if is
fascinating please don't shoot you when
do you get that when do you get the
location oh I'm sorry but that's when
all the planes are flying over so we
won't be able to shoot because the
planes make too much noise up so you
have to shoot it in the morning it's
incredible yesterday without going into
too much detail one of these guest
actors who was amazing got sick he just
had a collapse he had a nausea Evan yeah
but that everything stops and now we
don't know now we got a push but he
figured out together lose them they
don't know but he was brilliant I figure
it out for it I work with these kids who
work as good as it gets these [ __ ]
kids start at 6 years old by the time
they're 15 they have as much experience
as I do you know any problems yes child
actresses do well they get home-schooled
it's a very interesting situation they
what's a weird world for them to write
like the attention they get at that age
like I don't think oh I don't think
grown men are meant to have that sort of
notoriety and attention little ona
kid cuz they miss out being a kid it's
nice thing you know like look at that
girl Millie Bobby Brown where the [ __ ]
her name is the the stranger things girl
yeah how old is she
look her at last night on the red carpet
at the VMAs I was like let her be a kid
man yeah which one full dolled up she's
that my voice oh yeah she plays well
she's 14 Brian and since she was 9 she
done red carpets and every time like how
the [ __ ] is that a kid
this is the one who plays zero or
whatever yeah or 11:11 oh good lord
okay yeah she's adorable yeah there's
there's one where I want that I was
working it I was working it for E and I
could hear certain people making
comments and I'm like dude she's 13 you
look at some of the [ __ ] she's worn like
just type Bobby Brown award show or red
carpet and you'll see there's one you're
like dude who's telling her weird I
don't [ __ ] that stuff she's a kid I
think it's the Golden Globes but but and
also look at how much pressure is put on
looking perfect okay even alright it's
not a kid yeah yeah but they are I will
say this about all the kids I've ever
worked with and I'm really not
exaggerating the ones that work like
this are kind of brilliant oh yeah
they're so smart
mm-hmm they like they their home school
they never get anything but straight A's
they're just their parents are creative
and but people like Justin Timberlake
Matthew Perry all those people were all
child actors if you look at a lot of the
ones that have just been working forever
you can go back and they were Mickey
Mouse Club just generally yeah Mickey
Mouse though he started all than Britney
Spears they they were all doing this
[ __ ] dancing and singing at a very early
age I mean the girl I work with Sarah
Crowe Rachel Crow put up and put in
Rachel Crow she was on the voice at 13
years old
bring it Rachel Crow 13 never had a
voice lesson x-factor Sam right there
well listen to her she's she's on she's
she's great on my pilot listen to her
sing for us she's doing well she was 13
let's go ahead and hear her at 13 that's
hurt hear her at 13 with she just never
took a lesson just you know just decided
to go this has it huh yeah X Factor
let's just do that real quick there she
is right the the X Factor she looks cute
e pie huh you kid yes yes how old is she
good person hoping to get at least the
three yeses oh did she like factor in
the England
Rachel Crow 13 looking at cutie pie
she's such a sweet person - cutie she's
in eighth grade she already a regular on
your cell yes she's a regular
she's so what did she do before this she
was a singer she was a singer I forgot
her dance him just to make it on olia
kidding Vita did she make you on
x-factor
yes yes she made you want it or no yes
she she I don't know if she wanted but
she she's a killer
and she just talent she told me she
walked in and heard Jennifer Lopez
Jennifer Dodd Jennifer Hudson singing
and she had to sit down oh my god they
say that she's the best best of the
month so you sit down when you see she
finish I think third or six American
Idol
way to go America who cares look at her
she's all grown up now it's just so
funny to hell does she know 35 no 35 now
it's just 2011
she's so serious I was not this she's
just confident now mind you this is a
girl who had never had to love voice
lessons really she was just hey what
kind of ass clowns look one point six
thousand dislikes what kind of ass with
this life is mr. dad but our moms are
dad boy yes is he easy not there no he's
there he's super dense I met her dad
game set expectation I do an American
guts to American Idol just they have all
the same host they're right Simon's
creation I think he knows hunger she
doing stand-up right now no way look at
how badass she is it there Tom fidence
is insane she's just she's just got it
[Applause]
[Music]
boy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
showing out she's definitely like she
has that yeah natural will you call it
yeah on a TV show so there's you can act
yeah
have you done a new songs lately chin I
did what you do
it's another cover by the way I have an
original coming out that all beaten that
I'm putting with an animation so
eventually that's gonna be fine yeah oh
as Brian toys gives me crap for not
having an original hey did you hear that
song that we kind of wrote with our dick
song we have him sing it just impromptu
and see can we have chin and then maybe
we can jump in
I don't know is that is that appropriate
right now we have him we got descended
to chant I haven't looked at that much
yeah well maybe you can while he's fine
it chin bring up the one you just did
oh it's on your Instagram or is that
it's on my YouTube bridge there too bro
yeah don't be shy all right buddy um
Aladin what's an Aladdin you do Aladdin
voiceover yeah oh you slay this then we
watch Aladdin why is why did I lose my
email my phone
what's his song kids someone else to
start by Brian White she was fun would
you say comedy would you say single as
[ __ ] guys out there this for all you
other serial killers
hey there's you have zero dislikes stars
pretty qua someone move the ruins tear
saying i'm to breath eva which i'm do
black wratih i'm to suck dick how about
that - breathy what do you [ __ ] Simon
Cowell
[Music]
if you think that I could find
true
it happens all the time
[Music]
you should play you sing us every time
someone declined someone on tinder like
this just comes on
[Music]
why'd you pick this song afraid of songs
now the course is nice though then let
me hear the original that that Brian
white down there yeah and we compared to
the pro here looks like looks like a
young deal Vaughn that we got a [ __ ]
together
looks like a feel Vaughn who makes smart
choices in his wardrobe any of the
mean-ass fanny pack where's that fanny
pack no I said on the list of it
that's the sound country to you yeah
sounds like an Oklahoma angel yeah Jen
it's definitely a country song the
lyrics are really good Wow still slow
though yeah a little slow go slow
holds up wait for the ladies though huh
you don't have anything more up-tempo
let me see that Latin thing real quick
you know what you do for at Ladin so it
was a class project I just did all the
voices and everything you hear except
for the instrumental music so basically
everything here except for the music
just no way you're only in trouble if
you get caught even though a monkey you
all choose me all the characters but not
in real life
yes fine that's no joke and all the
sounds you can tell me we did this for
the movie no ho well no he did it as a
class a class project it's a remake of
it
[Music]
[Music]
all the voices even these [ __ ] your 13
year old count I got 48 therefore you
out creating you all voices in the
ladder should just one up your girl
[Music]
already cool yeah that's sweet bucks
that only have a thousand views I only
started this hey Jen yeah your favorite
what still till Brian what you did this
weekend uh-oh go ahead uh uh what would
you guess B I would say you did a lot of
we did some wakeboarding and some Heil I
probably had some Korean barbecue right
imagine Christmas okay all his money at
Korean barbecue I always picture him
having Korean barbecue and then for some
reason hanging out around the TV with a
bunch of friends who don't possess
genitals for for whatever like there's
no there's just friend no genitals no I
don't know just kind of tell me what you
did chin so I did get Korean barbecue
Stan yeah but then afterwards we went to
karaoke but a special kind of karaoke a
nude karaoke well not new it's like your
brothel bro and you think dude we talked
about this before like if you have
connections you can get into this
special case where they bring in girls
someone reached out to me to connect me
and Brian to it really be careful
anyways so just set the scene form so
it's a dark web karaoke place and they
bring in they back up the brakes of hose
and they let these hoes come in - hi -
your broom do you got a vent so now you
got singing and hoes yeah bro seeing
hoes well drinks well he's singing then
the hoser watch singing drinks yeah like
you're [ __ ] Elton John just rockin
man me
but you know this is I have a long yeah
that's you right and then at your knees
are these beautiful women who are there
on their own goodwill looking for money
they're working so you pick those girls
out they live for they live for for song
for cocking song they live for for a
shitty Revo shitty shitty version yeah
[ __ ] train so I ask you a question
with Hootie and the Blowfish and [ __ ]
and I want to ask you something yes so
do you think what was that Hootie and
Bookfest I let it ring dolphins make me
cry dolphins make me cry just that
that's a that's it yeah do you think
that while she's taking care of taking
care of the situation's there when she's
down there and so I'm gonna think you're
my dolphin yeah now and and you're
you're up there with your terrible it's
going to let it ring dolphins going to
cry or whatever that yeah gives a [ __ ] I
love that song yeah me too
he's a big kid you're singing that in
the terrible waste our ears are hurting
do you think that in her mind she's like
I could have made some better decisions
no I think she's saying this is awesome
this is I could be in a strip club when
it's done here listen to good tunes
there's good food right he picked me and
she'll check it out
listen Brian so they back up the brink
trunk full of hoes yeah out of the bring
truck assembles this team of hoes yeah
like the Power Rangers with tits and
asses yep and then you go wow cool I'll
take the Green Power Ranger with the
Blood ass I'll take the Black Power
Ranger has taken the racist the black
colored Power Ranger you have two fat
titties okay thank you other Power
Rangers not for me because you like
second yeah let's go into this room yeah
well I [ __ ] break out some Aerosmith
and you suck ditch so you your animus
tree my dream oh yeah dream on dream on
tell you a dream - and I'm your dream
money enjoy that sure whatever you want
man so I gotta listen to that sorry guys
no no prefer prefer up for me yes yes
not for that I just wondering if chin
yeah here what's worse is it the is the
is it the strange dawn in their mouth or
is it the is it the fact they have to
listen I'd say the shy voice is saying
I'd rather suck dick then here just I
think it over and over I think I would
do to have to hear you
got the tool with the fliction shirt and
the pierced ears
singing [ __ ] Nickelback yeah never
made it as a wise man yes like the nesco
never made it as a four-man sir yeah I'm
seeing Nickelback that I'm singing
Nickelback well you suck my [ __ ]
never made it as a wise man yeah get in
there girl get tongue deep no never made
it as a poem help me to some bad some
gay hell room in Koreatown and I'm like
no let go back don't do it he's I kid it
this is how you remind me yeah jerk me
with your feet real shoes huh and by the
way when you're singing the high notes
or your singing you're really singing
loud humbucker your your your your your
starfish herniates a little bit it pops
out and pinches you though
that's so terrible I can't I got one in
the Rose because when you did oh you you
know your your rump it there's and then
I'm giving out bonuses like Dana White
if you can make me bus while hid behind
all God trusts poor human being I I this
is the this is the reason I don't place
it don't place so that's I don't know
it's this how you remind me by
Nickelback
I don't indulge in brothels cuz I don't
want to subjects dude they're not really
brothels
no no they're karaokes with hot [ __ ]
your mommy right yeah that's it bro just
mm-hmm
now think of me and Brian with our
three-piece sets out and just wife
beaters on with some drinks and a
roomful of how various and a roomful of
house and you know what we only have
finger food we only have mozzarella
sticks and chicken wings who is this guy
and I smell like buffalo [ __ ] cheese
and ransom I'm gonna take my shoes off
if you don't mind
oh no you guys mind if I take off my
lucky Jews confliction shirt is that
cool with everyone dude and prostitution
has been around since the beginning of
time I admire admire when I say sorry
roofing story I had this [ __ ] album
young
I do die celebrating it cold bad they're
actually [ __ ] all y'all don't like
nickel bag right yeah I talk about
Metallica a little people get it well
people don't realize about Nickelback is
if they just showed up in a bar starts
singing you'd be like these guys are
phone I'm glad you brought that up
because my buddy you know my buddy my
buddies was this very famous friend
who's in a band and they're at a bar off
Pico where there's karaoke and strangely
enough the lead singer of Nickelback was
there and they would request song Geo's
nope only Nickelback songs and he sung
his songs over and over he like it was
like goddamn nice sang his own his own
songs so what do journeyer no no only
Nickelback oh that's very make some
words net that's all the hoes are Pico I
guess real man then they're married but
goat and then remember their big song I
think was super superstar that was the
jam bro I was in high school just these
guys have good voices
how long ago they're actually good
they're just hated why are they hated
people cuz I can listen this one tell
you I hate him because they have a
hundred twenty four million views
[Music]
see I'm singing this while you jerk me
off not you but the hurrah don't save me
yeah that's right yeah now I'm singing
this while you jerk me off in your
[ __ ] chicken wing so much hey I think
we should bring the ship back I think
they're outstanding you too bro
I think Nikolai should we make him the
official ban of firing the kids
I think Nickelback is outstanding and so
many videos or records but don't be
surprised if I show up with a tattoo
dude dude this is such a flashback big
and rich that Kendra Wilkins chocolate
Dell
[Music]
Ben Wayne Gretzky's son
[Music]
good lord Dale Earnhardt jr. a lot of
star stars oh wow
Paul Wow who's that Paul he's that white
rapper from Houston you know all these
people
[Music]
rock star
cuddles be great okay you can stop it I
just like that song
do I good like that son or the bye bye
damn good and they were huge right yeah
they're fussing so right so doesn't that
sound doesn't doesn't sound like a nice
time and I can set that up for us right
yeah and we would have a grand old time
there I gotta learn that song yeah for
sure but listen this chin tell them what
your night was like now take it Oh chin
here you're bringing it full circle
garnish it get it tell me tell me your
experience good that's how he brought in
girls yeah how many dude there's like
four rounds three rows four rounds so
one round is how many girls six three or
four or five three four five as you say
five let's say five 15 girls told round
first round dime pieces sec round dime
pieces third on dime Korean all Korean
nah they're mixed really white girl
she's like whatever you like you don't
say whatever you like really yeah so
carry on Jan 15 different girls all my
flavors
my friends pick two all their girls but
uh I said I didn't find the one I wanted
so I went the night without a girl yeah
but you know what Jen yeah can I be
honest with you yes at least you're
admitting ah that to the fact that you
you go to places that have ladies of the
evening okay and I admire your honesty
now now do you think and again yes tell
me this out bro put your Sherlock Holmes
do you think that you'd the reason you
can find one of these young ladies and
it's at fine but but do you think that
no judgement you didn't find one of
these many and we agree that there's a
variation different beautiful women of
different shapes and sizes so these do
the United Nations of baskin-robbins a
horse
okay so 31 flavors that maybe the
reasons was either trepidation or shy or
that one of them didn't have a big
enough [ __ ] and balls for the hairy
chest is that or that although or they
all have a heartbeat
did that drive you crazy did you wish
they were cold and clammy and by cold I
mean damn you're looking for a
middle-aged man
like myself that you could kill in the
basement and drill into his brain and
then get his powers by sucking his heart
think so those are the questions that I
have I don't know
good what do you think it was gin I did
the one see I was succumb to the
pressure where my friend like dude pick
or like I take [ __ ] Brene over there
give me Renee I kept thinking that
they're gonna keep bringing them through
but after on four rounds and I kept
saying no they just said screw this guy
your buddy's like I'll take her I'll
take it so they took one from the first
round and second round see I'm always
afraid that I'm gonna that to do that to
go to the place where they parade them
out in front of me yeah that that like
the poor yeah the girl I'm like ah and
she's like I gotta I gotta be with this
51 year old [ __ ] guy think I've seen
on TV before
ah now it's wrong bro you get the glass
half in you're a big dime P na but dude
you're a big dude if you don't have to
go to they got giant hashtag no races
Korean Chinese men to church [ __ ] Inc
did come dig this [ __ ] I know [ __ ]
drop in barely any cash meanwhile you
come in good guy you're not gonna hurt
them now
gift them your giant piece I've seen
your [ __ ] good-sized [ __ ] back and
they're gonna treat them right you
didn't do what's your real name
you figure out what you're into acting I
get some contact let me get your number
boom you make it connect yes that would
be marriage of the glass that would be
my understanding of my mo are in strip
clubs I'll pay it you're not dance and I
talk to them correct me so I can so I
can be different than the other guys
that's my that's help with that and by
different means I'm not gonna be mean to
you to get this pic different way you
got a zigzag around the issue but I
think half full yeah you I feel like you
go in there with your thick hair and
your your your shoulders for days your
breath and they're like that would G
nope
I talked to an actual stripper one time
like a legit famous stripper yeah and
she goes when you choose this is the
rule this is always the rule unless it's
like a famous rapper or a really famous
actor who's single if a good-looking guy
comes in with good-looking friends we go
away from them because those guys aren't
gonna pay that much for what the other
single lonely rich guys I think they go
so it's a waste of time while you're
looking for girls your work yeah she
goes its workforce
she was when I try to make relationship
we know you're good-looking dude I'm not
trying to get me know that I go we know
when you're a good-looking dude so you
can get girls so you're not gonna be
willing to go as far as these other
dudes we're looking for the frumpy bald
fat white dude who clearly has a small
[ __ ] with a lot of money you're not the
guy we're looking for
yes good so when you come in there's a
reason why they [ __ ] run like [ __ ]
[ __ ] I was in love with a stripper and
in there yep and I would go and pick her
up and her working oh I remember
standing there waiting for her and she
was in the back room with a guy and I
was like she's in the boom-boom room
what's really going on and he took this
is a very new no that's crazy talk how
about dude can you believe that with
chin I just it did you think it's more
of a fear thing chin way like god I
don't want it oh I've had I don't think
the girls have had girls there before
would you turn around are you by
yourself with all your fat we're in a
group that's another weird thing to grow
on your lap she but yeah at around if
she was super hot then I would I'd do it
but yeah I didn't find one super hot
here's a tip from a pro and I'm not
talking about me I'm talking about
another dude who's not named Brendan
I've been to these things that had a lot
of money
you go in there say how much you making
tonight she has this much very cool I'll
pay that let's go to my room where it's
not as [ __ ] ki our dude that happens
that masher yeah what do you mean
happens all the time sure it does are
they saying you do it all the time like
you love the [ __ ] we do it yeah and you
in Koreatown chin there's a hotel room
there for $12 next door what is it what
is the you get some the dice that's a
really good question if you don't have
to pay for it I know you have to pay for
it so the room alone and then you have
to get a bottle like bottle service so
you're paying for the bottle I think
that's like 200 300 bucks and then they
gave you fruit and food if you want it
you said free I have no Justin food in
that situation did the dream okay I like
a good meal what kind of food or eat oh
I grow with a fruit platter
no they'd they serve root a fruit
Huy and watermelon not what's not
excretes is it fresh melons like fresh
from the farmers very fresh
not into it what other food can I get
not like some walk on snow no that's not
like someone cons I'd like some egg
rolls maybe it's nice Chinese food and
I'd like a nice I don't know if you're
having ronnied with some with some
seared liver please if I could pick a
side of hummus cause I'd like to wash it
down with a dark roast coffee yes I like
to swish that around my mouth so my
teeth are bright and then I'm gonna kiss
this young looking baby you got it I got
a $5 bill on your name come on first of
all I want to sing in your face and then
if the night goes on I'm not I to you
guys
I'll be farting oh yeah oh this small
room on me farting I'm gonna get myself
nice nice and clammy down there and then
we're gonna also when I sing I get
nervous so I sweat a ton and I got swamp
ass and those spring rolls bring more
than just a few there Hoss to play one
time in Sacramento and this dude who was
in the play he was just you ever meet
you ever been in a [ __ ] like you you
just did a room and there's a guy who's
just loud and shaky and just he's just
George jolly guy yeah just kind of a
kind of a you know just a guy he's just
there and he's just loud and and his
eyes are buggy and there's just
something off just something just
something off its the sharp after you
talk about right everybody's playing
music and I was like you know me I have
it's very hard for me to be intolerant
of anybody I like pretty much everybody
you're less than that that way but for
me and this guy and I was like this guy
is gathering me he's just in the room
and he's just talking a lot and so
familiar with me and patting me like you
know yeah yeah patting me like hitting
them like I shot in the shoulder and
chucking my shoulder I don't know yeah
I'm like man this guy I'm trying to get
trained and then he goes see him in the
corner he's got his ass like his ass is
pointed at the corner of the room his
pants
he's he's leaning over and look at his
bug eyes he's wiping his oh my god I go
I go what are you doing and he goes I
got swamp ass bro I'm just well I'm just
holding up my buddy Tim goes he's got
swamp ass you got swamp ass that's it
it's too cool just wiping his ass in my
face I'm sorry so more the story
don't bring chin to those brows eggy oh
but the price so it's like a hundred and
twenty hundred fifty bucks to have that
girl with you for like an hour to and
then you gotta tip them afterwards I
would have to give her what's your right
now here's a tip don't do karaoke with
shitty dudes here's your tip don't smell
like hummus and [ __ ] chicken fingers
and do karaoke with these weird do
that's right there's your tip that's
right that's exactly must make a ton of
money even my goddamn nickel back to you
I mean my goddamn neck go back shirt and
sandy cuz that's what I came here for
yes I know you guys get are legally
printing him in the back yeah correct
you are correct sir
dude that's a business they must be
making a ton if they're always coming by
there but peep this if I ran one of
those brothels and I'd say who's your
butcher what who you gonna sing tonight
and then in the sweatshop in the back
everyone working so I create old-school
vintage tour t-shirts you get your dick
sucked
we got wontons yeah that's beautiful
ladies yes karaoke the drinks you're a
boom package yeah then you guys getting
vintage tour keys what band you like
your Smith
strike it up Wow we oughta just dinner
to sweating back there yes
three hours you'd have a whole operation
going you'd be a good pimp dude would
you have a nickname I mean just the
brown Oh Brown like Dan you know the
brown don't you don't don't toss the
brown you don't want the brown to come
to help [ __ ] with the brown take some I
mean back in don't mess with one his
[ __ ] dude yeah yeah you'd be enforcer
yeah but I don't want to be like the
weird parts of town like you know no
disrespect to wherever this brothels are
at but I like that want to do it off
flavor the hills mmm like Rodale or well
you know there are these agencies I have
it on good authority where if you want
to drop coin I don't remember
yeah you gotta drop between 1,500 and
$4,000 try six grand a pop no worry
saying hey they won't they will any girl
I've ever seen in a magazine oh god I'm
sorry
what squat yes I'm in your throne idiots
grab all that you've never seen us on
there so you want to spend the money you
want five grand you okay
if you want five grand there are there
are certain agencies where there there
are certain women there certainly anyone
you've ever seen on Instagram yeah that
did you say somethin it's around them
what okay all right but I've heard if
you know that if you pose and the covers
of in you know playboy Penthouse
whatever it might be that of hmm I'm
willing to pay for it all of them do you
think whatever you want
yeah true story yeah money the money
it's a weird world out he buys you buy
weird I mean awesome yeah the rich the
super-rich have a whole there's a whole
this is rich maybe you want maybe you
work in 95 and just save your money year
round do you want to [ __ ] the girl you
see on the cover that string can make
that happen that you can make it happen
we need a kid like God can never get
there know if your list this young kid
you can yeah you can just gotta save
your money it's gonna be older about
time get there I know a guy his discount
I know a guy who worked for a very
famous rock and roll band and this rock
and roll band was nope they had bad but
you know may as well be kissed he CDs
wasn't but but they had their girls when
they would tour and and that the
professionals that they would pay now
they have more money than God
so there and the money to irani who
worked for them for one of them said I
never done that never would and the lead
singer said really is that what you
think huh
how much you want to bet now my buddy
goes all the money in the world I just
don't do that it's not my thing and I
just could never do it and he goes okay
cool
and they all kind of snickered and my
buddy told me that his door there was a
knock at his door around
I don't know 11 p.m. and he said that he
found out later that that this was a
$5,000 a night or our young lady and he
said dude I opened that door and she was
without question the an angel she was on
the um hell she was non yell
and as a man I say name's William yes
yes and he said I've never seen anything
like it and I said did you let her in he
goes I sure did couldn't get her in fast
not a Ferrari came to the door all that
stuff I said to myself went out the
window and he said so there are women
out there that will bring you bring you
to your knees I don't care who you are
they'll bring you to you says money
doesn't money - money will break you
will break your back sometimes I want
that ain't no chin you want that chin
yeah I don't think you want that angel I
don't think you're ready for that I'm
ready I don't think you're ready for
this open my door like that and it's an
angel I don't think you know what to do
this is chin Anson or what happened my
buddy told me in Florida he called a
young lady and she showed up she was
preggers she was preggers John and
didn't have a whole lot of teeth on the
left side of her face my buddy was like
he just looked at anyway usually gave
her cash this get out of here like you
don't need to do this for your child
meant yeah here's a hundo you'll have to
do anything not in not in the baby what
do you have some soft hands all right
you know Jesus Christ weird world man
dude how about I have these guys and I
don't know the statistic you might be a
little kid up chin but even David Spade
said this his house got broken into and
they said most the time it's from a lot
of times from the people working on your
house whether you you're doing a new
deck the lawn service the up the
landscape whatever it is there's
connections through there there so years
ago my house got broke into from sources
that lead to that that are from the
landscaping I don't know what exactly it
is so have these guys worked on my house
right now - twice we got eight o'clock
no one shows up and they're in the
middle of this project it's a disaster
they have to finish this because I can't
leave the front of my house how it
finishes I know where is he doesn't show
up calling guys texting like dude I have
to get this done my kid can't walk out
we gotta go out the side like it's a
disaster please we got to figure this
out then finally the three other workers
come they go
he got picked up for grand theft auto
last night what the [ __ ] man this guy
was all up literally sitting in my car
we're talking about cars my [ __ ]
that's a nice car here so yeah I know
yeah so what can you do first get strong
oh yeah they do
oh yeah oh they do we've seen the movie
[ __ ] deal but I feel like those cars
those cars are so easy to see in spot
that you can't really nice piece of
change but you can be like oh my car was
stalling just look for the only Porsche
like that
yeah but they can take you to who knows
where and chop it up a chopper that up
though they I mean that would be it's
hard teaches metal I yeah oh yeah I feel
like that's too hard to hide now because
by the timing I who knows but it is a
bomber man Wow
crazy right people who live nearby
that's that oh yeah I know I just like
what the [ __ ] I don't know what you do
cuz you need those security and uh me
too dogs me too now ya guns I had
cameras and I said hey let the guy know
you know you seem like a good dude but
just let him know literally everything
you guys do is recorded and I've guns in
sight like it's just I don't know if
he's thinking about coming this way
whatever it is but I need that's done so
you guys finishes that this we're going
separate ways I'm gonna pay you but just
know everything you guys do I see
everything's recorded I have security of
dogs at [ __ ] guns yeah just let me
know that for me yeah and these guys are
great tonight dude we can we do that's
not our style what's going on there we
have for sure stuff that's a job for
some people men some people that just
could it just a bummer I mean the guy's
been there like you said he's doing this
projects he's been the fer grant to kind
of what kind of sentence that I don't
know it's probably depends on how many
you know how many offenses you have I'm
not talking about the video game yeah is
that there's that scene and you see that
movie the Ozarks when the drug dealer
and the pilot has his gun on Jason
Bateman mm-hmm and and the guys and he's
gonna kill them
they're like I swear to god I never
stole that's the first time and
the guy says the guy who's got the gun
says you know my father had off
convenience store and so lady it worked
for us for many many years they caught
her stealing just a small can of soup
one day she begged and said sorry but he
fired her anyway I thought it was so
unfair
because it was just a can of soup I said
you know why fired her said starts with
it he said cuz that was the first time
she wasn't the first time was this the
only time she got caught he just killed
all them jason bateman goes you guys you
know why and he goes yeah she'd been
doing it the whole time this is just the
first time she at least to Geico when
you have a habitual behavior yeah it's
not something you're just gonna do that
once stretchy chance and you doing it
once and then I catch it's like child
molesters when a child comes out forward
you know he would molest me
all of a sudden the guy gets 50 it's a
non-stop sudden oh by the way did that
to me by the way he did that to me by
the way he did that to me dude you want
to speak of it the complete one 180 here
but you want to talk about a [ __ ]
bomb fest did you see Madonna last night
the video MTV Music Awards oh no she was
supposed to do a [ __ ] dedication to
Aretha Franklin she got up she was to
sing her song no no just to do like like
a you know like a tribute to her okay so
she just said get up there oh and what
happens she makes it completely about
herself that tells a story you might
talk about the most narcissist on the
world so she does this and people
roasted the [ __ ] out of her not to
mention she looks like a straight
[ __ ] white Walker from Game of
Thrones she looks crazy she dressed up
as Jesus mmm basically with horns on her
face and then gave the worst tribute
you've ever heard in your life yeah
let's hear that is that possible because
I was long it's so bad she was you know
one thing about her wreath and then her
story on how she got her start and she
goes you know there I'm telling straight
for a reason because when I was in
France I heard a wreath for a song and
that's why I'm singing now it was
[ __ ] terrible wow that's terrible
this breakfast club breakfast club [ __ ]
I was like okay I love this guy
Charlamagne he's brilliant Franklin
changed the course this is it right
there
you want watching video of in here well
then they asked me if I had sheet music
and a song prepared fortunately one of
my favorite albums was ladies soul
I don't need sheet music I said I know
every oh that's why she dressed it when
I was finished they said we would call
you one day and maybe soon finally the
phone rang and it was one of the
producers saying we don't think you are
right for this junk we think you have
great potentials we want to bring you to
Paris and make you a star so that was
the beginning of my journey as a singer
you're probably all wondering why I'm
telling you this this is them cutting it
up by the words none of this would have
happened without our Lady of soul she
know she went on 15 minutes but they cut
this do you want 15 minutes they so many
people and I want to thank you Aretha
for empowering all of us our es PE CT
now did that seem long and drawn-out
that was a minute at the point I want
you to know that the original speech
uncut is six minutes 12 seconds
boom Donna talking about herself and
then tagging or that's what she does at
the end I refuse to believe that Madonna
blew anybody away with a rendition of
any Aretha song alright she simply
doesn't have the vocal chops to pull
that off second of all if someone could
give their own eulogy it would sound
exactly like how Madonna's sound third
of all I don't know why this just dawned
on me but it Rita Franklin passed away
on Madonna's 60th born day all right 60
is a milestone and this Madonna's born
day so you know how they had that
backdrop of Aretha behind Madonna as she
was talking when it comes to Madonna's
born day and her turning 60 Aretha
Franklin dying is definitely in her
rearview it's just a backdrop and when
things are in your rearview they're
behind you so you can't really see them
okay you're not really checking for
things in your rearview which leads me
to my which leads me to fourth okay of
all the ultimate aim of the ego it
is not to see something okay the
ultimate aim of the ego is not to see
something but to be something but Donna
doesn't see it for Aretha because she
too busy being Madonna which I will
never understand you
she's a straight guy Charlemagne yeah
he's a beat I love that guy she's
straight narcissist when you watch this
job what literally they pay into the
crowd and people like this it's the
worst moment in MTV Video or yes it was
the [ __ ] worst man yeah and before
that JLo just destroyed the stage they
gave her this huge like her entire
career war and she sung all her songs
there's a beast
and then they go to Madonna and he like
what and she looks like [ __ ] and she
looks like his dress Halloween project
it was like that that soul should take a
white Walker yeah well I don't know if
he ever saw ERC Madonna with her English
accent she was sort of sound like that
there no no she had a strapless accent
god you spent the summer Nina hadn't
gotten back with the thick British let's
hear that English accent a hearse it's
kind of she's crazy and I'll say this
I'm gonna say that she's overrated as
[ __ ] I'm doing a movie I with whoever
the designer who's great and Dick Tracy
under me what I'm wearing right now is
who you want big boy hurts her boyfriend
and passionate about it I knew that it
was a chance for me as an actress and a
singer to do things I had never done
before and the Bushman is
[Music]
love makes all the difference it's way
worse because she was ready to die Ricci
right for a while I found her very I
don't using that brothel I would not
pick her it's synonymous with not asking
questions I'll say this too I don't like
one of her songs its robotic the only
thing I like that she does with Dick
Tracy percent I've got a little bit of a
crack still in my scapula and in my one
of my roots here comes the accent
searching thick tight I'm a
detail-oriented person and and I and I
like to have things my I can't believe
I'm telling you that she sounds exactly
the same through the years that did
nothing
yes she's an English woman yes she had a
thick English one for a while
it's tough hmm it's tough but I don't
know Elton John eats her - Elton John
does he was talking smack on her she was
so mean no also she doesn't perform then
she lip-synchs her music like she's not
a real artist he doesn't believe that's
why I mean compared Elton John she ain't
John still be sweating his ass off on
that piano oh all out of shape and a lot
of a lot of tireless ambition and got
her as she did all the Botox yeah she's
she's definitely gonna fight it's gonna
be people like that well as they get
older they don't they don't age they
don't go fairly into the night they
generally involving diet becomes her
like your bike just this I give up yeah
they fight it you know but did you guys
know or you have a TV chin right I've
had to return it
it broke yeah we what so did you get a
new one
yeah I'm getting a new one soon what so
it broke because you dropped or some
[ __ ] oh just the places I want addressed
in your guide like killing do you like
it they just don't work I got bad luck
with TV really so you send back and did
you get a refund yeah
oh so you're good so yeah no order new
one yeah cat you watch TV yeah barely
they read I win why
[ __ ] what do you I didn't watch it I
should have no it's one of my favorite
Awards yeah oh the VMAs yeah laughs
lumpy badly can we take a pee break go
ahead dude uh we're gonna do some
current events right now bro Kurt have
ended up dude that's it van it up all
right the all the event this isn't that
current it's a it's about a year old but
it's an interesting article about
Hooters locations decreasing because of
Millennials this is a pornhub study that
Millennials aren't interested in boobs
as much anymore
so they're correlating what the hooters
not shutting down which is kind of just
like a reach but how about how about
Hooters can't hire girls based off big
hooters anymore oh I know did you know
discrimination you keep that yeah you
have to tell your manager that that's
but now if you go by a Hooters like I
actually enjoy their chicken wings ever
been forever actually love their chicken
wings are delicious yeah I've been
forever but I went out when I would
training hi out to dinner roar there's a
Hooters across the street we go there
all the time
girls were there with some big-ass
titties computers now which one I don't
know price six years ago they got
mosquito bite titties now because they
don't want discriminate against ability
it's so weird it's like um but but
Millennials are not in that into boobs
but they're into ass yeah can I tell you
what they do so so the shows on the [ __ ]
that goes on with with with all the data
that is out there you can find out
anything so one of the things that
stockbrokers will do sometimes from what
I hear is they'll put cameras check this
out they got cameras in a Walmart Kmart
parking lot okay ready for this yeah
they can judge by how many cars are in
the Walmart's nationwide they'll tap in
they'll see how many cars are actually
parked in those Walmart's and they can
tell the stock is worth more so more
people are shopping right now than they
were before think that's one tiny
example of how some people can but what
this says Millennials are less
interested in breasts that than their
elders says pornhub visitors between the
age of 18 24 and 19 percent basically
20% less like you to search for breasts
when compared to all the other age
groups I have it me too but visitors
aged 55 to 64 17
percent more like you to search here's
my thing when I'm searching for porn I
assume they're gonna have some pretty
nice titties I don't need to type in
tits
unless I'm looking some just shy
enormous [ __ ] Dog the Bounty Hunter's
wife tits so they know the rest
breasts errata sizing the breasts is a
cultural thing and there are a lot of
anthropology to show you a lot of
cultures that have no there's no errata
sysm about a breast right so that would
be that would be the theory but the
third that meets the healthy female
right cuz big breasts means they can
feed the baby big ass means get a big
hip yes that's really say yes exactly of
course so so men are definitely
attracted to round smooth surfaces of
course but ground smashes so if you if
you look at the 70s in the United States
at least in white culture not black
culture but I can speak to mainstream
white culture and movie stars okay
you never really like from pretty woman
to Sharon Stone to whatever it was never
you never really it wasn't the JLo ass
it was me Rose legs it was legs and
breasts
yeah Marilyn Monroe's done the first
curve she is Garvey but again my mouth
her her her breast she was she was rude
she wasn't in tight spandex now with the
exercise revolution with women working
out and squatting and working their ass
and wearing tights up it's a whole
different thing
even when Madonna was the [ __ ] it was
about her breasts it was about her like
if you think about the nudity when a
woman showed her her her breasts and the
seventies whatever think about any
heartthrob girl any of the women that
were like the thing you never it was
never about their ass it was about their
legs it was about their there was always
frontal stuff it was always front ever
ask Miller I know living the best life
she can back then look at her bro oh
yeah just ask her if you read and I
didn't but my girlfriend the time did
read her biography or autobiography
autobiography the amount of [ __ ] she
did I I read it okay tell me about it
she was all about it like she didn't
have a problem with it yeah she would
say yes I would sleep with men to get
what I wanted because if I didn't do it
someone else would and how I made my way
she had no issues with it there was a
saying
she embraced it yeah she's literally
like yeah I'll suck dick to be the next
but he or she talked about sucking this
this she was in there in this executives
had his pants down and she was giving
him a [ __ ] and she said when are you
gonna help me he goes not yet but soon
and he pushed her head back then like
she said she did what yeah she did she's
just everybody she's beautiful God she
is gorgeous man and and talented she
died at 27 right no I think she was 30
joe dimaggio 27 I thought and not that
it was a choice I don't know I think she
was a fine she died in Hollywood yeah
you can go by the place where she died
to his 30s was she be I think she died
in Brentwood 37 she might even 37 36 36
[ __ ] son she was attractive love drugs
a lot of drugs was she killed or did she
overdosed that's overdose for sure
sucking dick don't coke poor thing
gorgeous though so I should back from
the day no one's really that curvy no
Mae West you ever seen me West no bring
a Mae West for a second brother Emile
Morello don't bro but when you're at it
while you're at it after that bring up
Rita Hayworth thank you to bring up I'd
also like you to bring up Sophia Loren
Mae West was the original she was the
original sex queen and this is what she
looked like she'd be I come up and see
me sometime big boy you know that [ __ ]
she I would say yo you get your ass out
of my face could be attractive huh but
two men back then she was all Kansas sex
I come up and see me sometime
nope not having you if there was 15 of
her in her bra thought to pull the chin
and I miss any she's not attractive at
all oh my
now please bring up so feel around young
so feel sorry she had something going on
yeah she's a badass she was real still
takes a dump on all of them but yeah I
mean she's attractive
hey when they show when they get older I
didn't order a bummer
yeah well then there was a Greg credit
that credit Garbo but bridge Brigitte
Bardot have you seen Brigitte Bardot no
you seen Brigitte Nelson was you again
Brigitte Bardot no beautiful but again
you never saw her ass look at her look
at Brigitte Bardot oh my God look at her
now goddamn it it [ __ ] hey age is a
[ __ ] earth to look at holes
damage in go to go back gin look at her
now she's now at a good picture
she's zebras that's a glove that's a
good picture of her oh this is probably
God dog that's what happens what did she
swap faces orangutan but that's what
happens with AIDS both cheeks like a
beet it's comedy human beat oh yeah
that's gonna be me you think my teeth
threw me any better than those there you
go no they're not right behind her gun
she's lived a glorious life she's had no
plastic surgery and there is a picture
of her that was the picture I think it
was the other one and the and it was a
Cosmo and it said and it just said
unacceptable it's like do something but
some women really age gracefully like
some just don't know the ultimate was
the conference number one the ultimate
though was Geno's men times bro who is
the who is the ultimate James pawn girl
oh my god the hottest girl of all time
oh my god it's blanking a blank counter
James Bond
I've been Bond girls the alt is Halle
Berry might be the best Bond girl
no I need to ring a bell she's in the
middle this one that's who you're
talking about
no Todd Cleon the top where there's
three girls far left top there you go
the girl in the middle right no no those
are all recent oh no the one the middle
is not recent brothers from the evidence
from the seventies Denise Richards
yeah well please go back for a sec I
gotta find this I cannot believe I'm
forgetting her name I'm getting old
though the hottest of all time
well maybe the hot there she is No Aki's
gone these are all the Bond girls bro
yeah keep concert maybe she's not on
here now the ultimate Oh No oh I don't
you know you you want to see odd-job
your theory for the odd-job gay no sir
oh I know who you're looking for you're
thinking of the bad guy jaws with tip
nose eye he was good - he was good he
was good I was talking about bo Derek
that's not no Derek I'm talking about
come on guys she's an she's an old
heartthrob and she's right this is the
one there to see the bathing suit yeah
no no that don't come over - right right
there no they did to the left right
there
Larry that's how I bury bro she's the
best love you like her you're gonna like
thee did this one I do I saw her walk
around the Grove uh uh she's in person
to do that one right there that one
right there's one the one to the far
left the far left right down down one
funny Joan that's the same Ursula now
that I'm out Ursula she has the worst
name of all the Bond girls a bird yeah
Welch Oh Oh what mrs. Welch reckon she
makes it delicious jam dude why don't
you say the girl who makes all that jam
that guy Welch
now go ahead and give me a go ahead and
get her when she was younger cuz it's
it's done take her with that bob cut off
my [ __ ] was astonishing well well
there are we we're so spoiled now
because Cindy Crawford's could drop a
[ __ ] Cleveland steamer all over her
oh don't say don't say it like that
don't go to Sydney why get mad so I
really exaggerated Cleveland steamer
what can you hyped it up with porch and
I just shitty searching just you know
you're like for hours you wonder
King you see Cindy Crawford oh we're not
we're not all made equal if an alien
came down to this
and found Cindy Crawford but yep let's
go yes we're not gonna kill you weren't
kill everybody all right sir the rest of
you are correct what else you got chin
Oh current events so Kobe Bryant you
heard about his investments six million
dollars into body armor yeah it was a
water burn you know some guys just can't
miss he won a [ __ ] Grammy or what do
you win Academy Award for his cartoon
that is without right when he retired
the next year he won a great economy
award for a scart day I forgot and now
he's like on vest six men under this
drink oh I have 200 million now of my
four years buy another helicopter I know
what that 200 million do that put gas in
my helicopter get around in the
[ __ ] just can't miss okay and you
ever see is uh the spotlight thing he's
doing there the NBA playoffs it was on
the ESPN Plus app but it was called like
the spotlight or something like that and
it was Kobe Bryant talking about the
game so the game would happen that night
the next day was Kobe Bryant in a dark
room it's telling you breaking it down
like a [ __ ] mad scientist what was
going on it's a rich brilliant he's such
a beast yes yes yes yes a master there
it is about time he got caught in
northern Colorado yeah give that girl
anal yeah that's a weird story because
didn't she rescind her story or just no
she got a she went just [ __ ] with you
all she got paid I'm gonna dip on out
real s she owns Greeley Colorado yeah
what'd she make on that mmm he gave her
Greeley Colorado yes sorry about the ass
play here's the town of green was the
original like sort of complained that
she was she was she was raped all right
yeah but she's in her bootie but she
came there and when she like well they
found two other but she races of semen
in her underwear from two other guys run
in the back no I don't think so yes yes
they found but then did it she wasn't
she like giving him drinks or some [ __ ]
was it she's a waitress or something huh
she accused of rape for her hotel room
the night before the surgery
Oh his surgery right Brian omitted
social encounter with his accuser but
tonight the assault
the case was dropped after Brian secures
refused to testify on the case a
separate civil suit was later filed
against Brian by the woman this was
settled out of court included Brian's
public of the apologizing today the
woman for Ashley in exchange got the
town of Greeley he's the mayor of
Greeley and that they did find the
answer all right know she had sex here
was the thing
she had it right before she had after so
she's saying she got raped and then went
stating that he had her from the
background her next ring that during sex
was the thing and he had a pattern of
straying different sex partners all
right well so he that's his thing
well yeah but he's not hurting them yeah
about fifty Shades of Kobe uh when I was
how hard was hold on her neck Brian said
my hands are strong I don't know if I
had some big hands he asked if he could
come on her face and she said no don't
say that's polite girls in the brothel
you'd have to nickel back your neck that
guy's just [ __ ] icing their faces -
you don't think about that right you
know then then I can [ __ ] the town if
he stayed married through that I think
he did he did figure it out if I'm the
biggest I say figure it out I mean he
went to Africa and had them dig up the
largest diamond ever seen and now she
carries it down like this yes yes my bat
for the ass plate a lot of shoes annual
Colorado it smells like [ __ ] up there
and this girl came to my room now here's
the biggest dime you ever seen in your
life aftermath eight months after the
initial incident the lodge and spa
remodeled as part of the salts and
furniture okay don't give a [ __ ] Kobe
Bryant lady stayed okay Bryant signed a
seven-year hundred thirty six minutes on
contract the year after allegations
because he came ball regained several
endorsements Nike Spalding coca-cola
smaller companies he was named the NBA's
most valuable player the next year the
Finals MVP
goddang she did file for divorce but
they didn't go
but however Brian's wife reconciled
January 13th because he went cool story
check this out goosh and scrooge mcduck
last sorry it's real hey hey listen
a diamond can go a long way I'm not in
diamonds what would I have to buy you if
I really screwed you over if you found
out that your kid wasn't nearly at the
athlete you thought he was gonna be but
he had a great personality and a great
sense of humor and had psoriasis and he
had a lot of psoriasis and all of a
sudden he looked a lot like good old
bride Oh Jeff the bonhomie I mean I like
watches bro cars I'll take ya into my
pocket and get you something I mean if
you got if you got me the vintage Paul
Newman Daytona I wouldn't be mad at you
okay I told you I told you the guy was
it there was chopper and the guy goes
well she's something call you a guy said
his dad left him this brought in
anything is this worth anything and it
was the Daytona [ __ ] the whitey that was
a good guy cuz this is worth a hardened
$30,000 it went further than the
original one that he wore went for
[ __ ] crazy money millions well there
it is such a beast we'll watch it dude
do they make some save the best do they
make like a new version yeah they do
they make a new version the white one
that looks like that is you know I can't
I would fly off the shelves
top right they fly off the shelves
really yeah
maybe everyone's aware that the those
are like 14 grand that's a lot of 15
grand
I feel like that's a lot of money for a
watch I mean I'm not gonna spend that on
a roll we're gonna make 30 grand to
afford 15 grand and I don't want watches
enough but I appreciate it all right at
least I don't have to I don't mind my
taste isn't very expensive it's a good
thing right there's always movement yeah
what else you got chin all right this
one is crazy
Asia Argento I heard about the recent
scandals just but she paid off an
accuser it was like $380,000 - it's like
a gag order so he wouldn't talk about
his sexual abuse that she did to him
wait hold on I'm confused I heard that
she molested a young kid how's auntie
Bourdain get
let me wait let me give you all the
details because I've really stole thats
why we're game paid it that if I'm a go
board Ryan yeah you know this you know
her backstory to hood the whole Roman
Polanski thing everything and then she
became this spokesperson for the me to
movement what's that remember you're
talking about the rules I said this I'm
Rogan a while back in Asia Argento who
was raped by Harvin Winston the reason I
believe her is because she did a movie
basically before any of this [ __ ] came
out that that was exactly like the story
she told her it's also it's also very
very closely correlated to a lot of
other very similar stories of Harvey
Weinstein's behavior so when Ozzie I
resent oh I believe she was raped by
Harvey one see when she was 21
there's no reason not to where things
get very complicated she kept that
relationship going
sexual relationship with Harvey
Weinstein for ten years afterward after
that yeah I even I even give her a pass
on that you know why cuz a lot of times
a fickle act here their thing okay okay
she was just afraid whatever is you
relive the trauma on your own turn okay
I'll give you that okay then she signed
the petition to get Roman Polanski
released I think when he was arrested by
the swiss p-- or to be extradited into
the united states and a bad dog that
worried the statute of limitations of
his part well he sodomized and raped the
13 year old after drugging can't help
that so what are we talking about okay
what are we talking to the devil yeah so
so um but she signed that then this me
to stuff comes out and she's the biggest
voice she gives an incredibly riveting
speech at con this was his hunting
ground we know who you are you you you
know we are more important we know you
are we're coming for you and all that
and she was she's the voice anthony
bourdain who was from what i hear from a
friend of his was head over heels in
love with her how was his girl that was
his girl that was the girl yes I head
over thousand small girl head over
[ __ ] heels okay yeah and she was
caught with another Danny he he before
that's a good guy picked up the banner
of the me to thing it was like I'm with
you
[ __ ] these guys who do the
because he girls oh yeah just like
behind her and everything else so she it
turns out and it comes out that she had
done a movie with a seven-year-old
she played his mother and she played a
prostitute okay
she keeps in touch with him throughout
the years for the next ten years she has
him meet her he's 17 at a reunion
meeting at the ritz-carlton suite in
Marina del Rey she's there she's smoking
she's got alcohol he shows up with a
family member he's like hey mom they
would call it to the mom and son she
says the family member why don't you can
you leave because I want to spend time
with him alone I know that's crazy
family I was like okay so now he's in
her hotel room she starts giving him
alcohol he's 17 age of consent is in
California 18 18 he's 17 she's giving
him alcohol shows him all these letters
she wrote to him on the stationery in
the room she then begins to kiss him
pushes him down the bed sucks his [ __ ]
jumps on his [ __ ] and [ __ ] some poor
[ __ ] kid which he did sad friend dude
that's a 17 year old boy Brett I have
never was 37 I'm furious I know and she
was 37 deities she was really she's very
held him down and swallowed his [ __ ]
hard to hold somebody now but she did
and he was a he was a sensitive actor
musician Brennan Tony he's gone I'm
sorry I mean I got the story I'm furious
okay you look outraged I have no because
I've you look out right now he they then
posed for pictures in the bed naked okay
which he has she has they then go and
have lunch where he begins the feel
disgusted mortified and embarrassed
quote-unquote now I guess he gets in the
car while she was this is great keep
going [ __ ] in the car so he's all
three because I had been on her case
before this for being a hypocritical
trust her I was mad at okay keep going
bro so now he begins to feel at a 17
year old he's like this was weird I
don't know what to do
look well I'm 17 you're set
Dean we're gonna have a little bit of
different reaction I can I can
like I remember 17 but he might be a
very sensitive kid also this is a woman
he had a relationship but she is 35
looked up to her that's that's over 17
37 that's all you're a fossil yeah I
used to make fun of that 37 is old
fossil lock you know that's a little bit
like too much right so I got by that it
began to [ __ ] for sure he's like it's
probably just like our musician he's not
he's not he's not a dog you know so so I
guess what happened was it got to a
point where he was like I this is [ __ ]
up and by the way um I can't work I
can't think I'm not I'm not you know so
because she's so traumatized he couldn't
work I guess and although his income
went from 2.7 million dollars to you
know 60 grand a year and I'm sure I had
nothing to do with it but he wasn't
making able to make money well sure it
sure it did it's a good day long story
short she hires the lawyer well quick
because he's like I'm gonna go public
with this or something no well oh by the
way 17 he's 17 that's a minor that's a
minor ladies and gentlemen so for she
pays him $380,000 now does she now a
court is our boy empty boards in my
heart this how could what duty is guys
back here goes he puts here
sorry interrupted be he goes he texts
her about this guy this kid Jimmy
Bennett referring him as the donkey
Bourdain writes that paying him is no
admission of anything no attempt to buy
a cover-up simply an offer to help an
obviously tortured soul who's desperate
and trying to jack you for money and he
goes on to say or you just tell him to
[ __ ] himself
either way I'm with you god that's
heartbreaking yeah that's such a good
dude
well the problem is that they TMZ and a
lot of other places a lot of other
people have text messages between Asia
and Anthony and more importantly got the
the legal documents but let me just say
what our gentian about what though I'm
deeply shocked and hurt by having read
news that is absolutely false
I have never had any sexual relationship
with Bennett the Bennett to which she is
referring as Jimmy Bennett who she had
to visit who as she had visited her in a
hotel room but why did she acknowledged
his hatha knee paid saying Anthony
personally undertook to hell
Bennett economically oh just out of four
three hundred and eighty thousand
dollars hmm
she goes to say Bennett was litigious
and made it exorbitant money demands and
they wanted to no longer suffer any
further intrusions in our life
interesting board and Argento who are
dating I believe this Bennett guy might
be a scumbag too for over a year before
Bourdain yeah yeah but what but I but
when you pay that into any cool guy that
was money something happen board ain't
the only cool guy in all this yeah of
course
God day that's hard I mean I think
Bourdain believes RA Asia and I'd also
like I'll see that my name's kids cat if
you can go away like whatever you want
to do I'm dead so he goes through all
this and then he finds out she's she's
holding hands and hanging out with two
other dudes one on Instagram and other
the other I guess on god damn this so
he's yeah I think so she liked the
weather dictate but so all of this was
bunk but there was an actor yes also 13
he sucks she sucks he sucks yeah what is
she from what movie sure yeah from xxx
that's right she's a [ __ ] from xxx oh
we love guys in the fur coats yeah um
wait hold on
he's at one point seems to contradict
her claim she never had a sexual
relationship saying I wasn't raped but I
was frozen he was on top of me after he
told me I had been his sexual fantasies
since he was 12 hold on hold on go down
yeah was it rape but I was frozen he was
on top of me after you told me I'd been
sick so now she's saying he she's saying
he rape her oh she knows she's saying
that he was a sex fantasy so
so wait go back go back up he was
referred to as the donkey which all can
only mean his dong was impossibly large
donkey and board and riding paying him
no admission of anything no attempt to
buy a cover up simply an offer to help
an obvious tortured soul who's desperate
and trying to jack you for money yeah
but dude is she the worst person keeps
rolling down chin I think we're Dan
believes also never addresses
photography an agent Bennett shirtless
in bed with their foreheads touching
this was really centerpiece with her
settlement I mean come on guys it's
shortly
bed so what you know what I'm saying
there did she did not want an NDA as
part of the settlement since she rallied
on Harvard lies Bourdain seems to agree
in the text saying you are not buying
silence only freedom from inconvenience
and to help a poor twisted goof get his
life together his response I will never
buy a science or something that isn't
true since I'm also broke Wow
yet all names in other texts that he was
the sexual aggressor and there it is it
says I'm I don't hear him I am no
Puritan Google my ass god damn it
Bennet claims angio piled him I mean you
know he had a hard-on jumped on top of
him Heather still 17 you know she sucks
he probably sucks she sucks Bourdain it
doesn't goddamn it and I think it was
too much for him out of all the [ __ ]
fish in the sea picked up this one that
sucks yeah that's what you're attracted
you can't help it huh yeah there's
something about this [ __ ] desperation
desperation makes people do crazy [ __ ]
those two suck what else get Jim oh just
lastly on this topic you know Rose
McGowan who's her she's her bigger piece
the favorite buddy so she's getting a
channel yeah so she's getting you know
backlash from the internet because she
says be gentle to that person all the
other guys I used that's interesting how
the problem is that these double
standards I know you got to be there's
got to be hard and fast rules you know a
Ben Shapiro said it really well I think
he said this he goes we need a very
clear delineation of what is considered
sexual harassment sexual assault
don't touch women who don't do not you
ever seen though that's women without
their permission you ever seen Rose
McGowan with Marilyn Manson three days
all right
I don't give a [ __ ] click on that I told
you what am i what are we doing but but
but but you know when people yell louder
mean he allowed to carry around with a
chain while getting yes thank you thank
you people got fired by the way for what
guys for for accusations of first coming
on to people for hugging for kissing
like saying kiss your cheek
oh my lord she is fantastic I'm such a
fan but I think she's a little crazy
oh you think what should a kid look at
that she's naked look at that oh wow I
don't have to astonishing I'm sick of
her what does she got Jim I I think also
I just want to say this that having been
in this business for so long a lot of
actors and actresses have a pathological
need for attention a pathological and
they're gonna find it and end one way
and are also complete narcissists and
are going to in their own mind either be
the heroes are the victims of everything
and find a way and I think there's a lot
of that know because she's an actor yeah
I think there's a lot of that she knows
yes I'm always amazed Kevin Spacey's
movie that came out that she's a tomcat
in the sack throw that out there well I
read she is a I will guarantee that I
would promise that I not today so I
hates dick I'm saying back in the day
talking about those are you talking
about 100% I chose that I said on this
bike Garfield in the sack said on my
podcast on this podcast my all-time
favorite hottest familial sexiest the
sexiest gal in Hollywood you know how
that way since doomed generation oh wow
yeah for you man was that again
Rose McGowan I follow up she's I still
think she's shaved head her hatred of
men I'm still a fan you like Jessica
Chastain and Jenny slate too right yep
Jenny slate I don't think Jenny slate
who's Jenny slate I like Jessica Jessica
knows Biel Jessica be able to scoop oh
and Jessica Chastain yes like a hundred
girl who's Jenny slate
I love Jenny slate but I like her as a
person Oh what's this chimp we got also
that's this is Kevin Spacey's movie that
debuted this Friday in select theaters
I'm going why would they cast him as did
it was also on the eight screens it was
also had no no advertising but people my
favorite was doing every week retweets
his input I had the whole theater to
myself so $126 on opening day
Jesus well yeah well me what do you
think was gonna happen
I can release it there's other actors
there that are good people
seven people went Jesus Christ yeah it's
pretty crazy what else you got oh so
this is a big deal for Asians around the
world got huge is this movie crazy rich
Asians its top of the box office it was
a book to right chin yeah read the book
now it's about time Cajuns had a movie
this is the first time right there was
rush hour one rush hour two big trouble
little China rumble in the bronze that
was fun that was one Asian guys Rumble
in listen everyone listen rumble in the
bran randon Godzilla one two ready yeah
baby sir but if I understand but that
was just some Asian actor Enter the
Dragon okay but that was a long time
that was all karate this is about The
Last Samurai karate and this Tom Cruise
in the Last Samurai
swords are karate this is like human
beings having like relationships
Disney's Mulan then Brendon Emperor's
New Clothes polities god damn it sorry
am i off to our to our Asian listeners I
want to apologize though I made some
legit [ __ ] points there rumble in the
Bronx didn't see it that movie so
[ __ ] classic with Jackie Chan oh I
remember that in the Bronx dubbed over
right why it was always one Asian guy
with a bunch of big white guy said he
was beating the storm kicks yeah yeah
yeah and he was the guy here you say
find the Asians up ahead hey Ching
chongs Hong guy and he'd be like I'd
beat the [ __ ] out of Victor Little China
did so do you have any desire to see
this movie much aging movie not really
really I heard it see people loved it I
don't know what it's about
I'm gonna watch it but I'll probably you
know I'll see on demand
I'd sarire I go that movies I'm
supporting if you watch on oh yeah and
then I can pay for a biopsy Rhonda man
yeah I want to see it on demand I will
illegally stream it from an Asian site
which is just as good
my wife was on Safari and they were in
Kenya and apparently the Chinese a bus
of Chinese oh were purposely separating
a baby gazelle from her mama cheetah
from the mother cheetah he did nope they
would just try to look at the cheetah
and keep the baby and so they separate
the mama guides got very mad and
apparently there was somebody in the
group of international people that my
wife was either with or close to that
she didn't know who screamed get your
Chinese asses the [ __ ] away from that
cheetah it was a very kind of tense and
they all looked over I said I'm talking
to you I think he was from Norway you
just panicked
I was trying to get the reaction out of
them it's not a really it's kind of not
really a very kind of my new Chinese
asses factor you know we get your
American asses out of here I'm not
offensive
get your Chinese asses and they didn't
move of course but did they're lucky the
[ __ ] cheated it ripped their faith
and they they shot the baby cheetah all
and she I mean there was nothing left
they live and dust and they'd the
cheetah made with chopstick yeah that's
I did not corroborate that story no all
right spitballing ideas here breasts
spittin ball
Stepan idea I want to say why watch this
Nemer and ate a cheetah with chopstick I
was moving as [ __ ] right now
I wanna see this movie bro I'm offended
you guys today just have no moves at all
yeah I said you said agents have no
movies I just ripped off I don't know 15
bangers Papa bangers if I'm very good
too it's like how it was like you were
ready for that I'm ready hippie you're
[ __ ] I celebrate Asian culture that's
her no she got gin this a woman got
killed by an alligator [ __ ]
in South Carolina yeah I guess she was
maybe trying to protect her dog and the
alligator was like oh I'll take you
they don't know they just saw witnesses
saw her walking her dog and then she
disappeared and the dog was fine and
she was recovered later Gators will kill
you huh and it's the first time I said
that another one happened in 2016 or
something but they weren't sure if it
was an attack attacked and pulled into
the water you know it is game [ __ ]
over when you entered the water well now
he goes let's go into my world you know
what the games that man no you're not
that's his that's almost his domain you
know fight and you know you know squishy
the bottom is so you're falling and it's
just over it's at least not to drag you
in nice and easy
he's an 8-foot alligator is eight feet
he's spinning he he's taking under and
then it's batted up like if there's
someone you're laying like oh my god it
but these in a spin cycle safe it's just
spinning valleys roughly two feet longer
higher taller than you and I guaranteed
some good for a good five six seven
hundred pounds so like is this tail has
all the muscle in the world and just
spins like a [ __ ] the laundry of
America and the American alligator has
some of the strongest jaws they say the
strongest jaws here and does not
discriminate no white black Asian he's
got a holy it does he does he does the
old death spiral probably called the
alligator roll for a reason yeah you
know I don't [ __ ] with lagoons anybody
get you and your jujitsu guy somebody
get you in an ankle lock sometimes
you'll roll with that ankle lock but not
rolling out of it but you're not you're
not in the jaws of an eight-foot way do
you think it's better
what's better if I'm if the if like if
I'm like oh what's in the water oh is
that a quarter hey I'll get it I'm in
the stomach yeah so I'm here yeah it's
fill up with water I can't see much but
I know it's game over you have to drag
down its darkest haha right pretty
stinky yeah or is it better where he
gets my leg I'm crawling but it's Dino
it's game over it's dragging me into the
water I'm gonna stay at first I'm gonna
say really yeah that's that's the
rational thing emotionally I I want a
little more air I want a couple more
seconds of air and I want a fighting
chance I also want my legs so I can turn
around and stick my fingers in his nose
and eyes yeah at least take an eye out
like I'm doing I heard there was a guy
who got bit and he's reached into the
Crocs [ __ ] and pulled stuck his hand
but how do you do that I'd be home it's
a myth right now I'd be a myth you get
their eyes though you get their I have
your you ever [ __ ] name any animal
name an animal name and have never tried
touching their eyes impossible yeah I do
I go for eyes I might go cool I you know
I'm saying yeah they shut them so tight
yeah try poking your dog in the eye when
you get home try poking your dog tonight
they will not let it happen yeah let
alone an alligator who can tuck and roll
the I know you're not the first person I
like okay go from I you stupid I'm sorry
most a lot of victims gorillas you know
those cars live the old Corvettes with
eyes go up and do these glass down
yeah if those yeah well it's like a
shark's roll their eyes in the back of
their head and it but it puts up a
protective layer yeah so you go to punch
darken that I take good luck bit yeah
you gotta go found gills bro and also
this is alligator really give a [ __ ] if
he's got to wear an eyepatch he's fine
he doesn't need both eyes like somewhat
cooler well you're just going huh yeah I
think headfirst soon the stomach's the
way to go so you don't see much yeah I
always think about this girl who dummy
dumb dumb dumb dumb dumb dumb dumb them
Peace Corps volunteer with this guy and
the guy was into her and she goes let's
go swimming
in that Lake slash River that's muddy
that you put a town are then there and
there in Kenya Africa so do you know
where you've got to stop safari and
where hippos are Kenya now if you go to
a random body of water in Kenya down at
the set of Lion King base you're not go
you know you know like I'm not going
oh that waters muddy why I do not have
you not ever certain it is she
undeniably hot though like if a hot
girls like he said he goes I almost
jumped in because she goes I'm either
going in with or without you and then
she got in the water and she goes in she
said it was no more than 30 seconds and
she goes she goes get in the water you
baby cut and she and she got she too
disappeared and then she came back up
and she screams right at him it had her
by the feet just pulled out yet he never
saw her you know she was a crocodile it
was a an [ __ ] craw craw casinos yeah it
was an African cracker Mouse or this
why's this skinny and it's just rows of
razor
please bring up mouths or their stupid
snout at this big and then their little
snouts are like a racetrack now that's a
Cayman this is an African crocodile
please the Nile crocodile take a look at
this oh you talk about the knives I want
to slice our Tama King no sir I'm
talking about the skinny nose why should
I get a play 16-footer sir I'm talking
about that that's where that's in Kenya
you know here be dragons they shot that
in Kenya or Tanzania here be dragons the
biggest crocodiles in the world that
that sir if you do that dude let me ask
some let me a that's a dragon hit play
the Sun Lake Victoria look look look
Lake Victoria play is sending out look
at those [ __ ] give that thing here
play the scenario for me let's say
you're in Africa and you're with who was
the hot girl let's say Marilyn Monroe as
well let's say Marilyn Monroe nyet her
heyday yeah in her heyday
you're on set together yeah she's like
what are you doing after this after you
have said you won't just go out for like
chill yeah that'd be great and your your
rock-hard in your pants you think you
have a shot with vintage Marilyn Monroe
we're talking she's 27 years old
sure puffy lips tits perked up her ass
out the back shirt mole yeah Joe
DiMaggio's girl right but she's looking
to [ __ ] the kid yeah you're in Africa
you get done with set she was let's go
get a beer something you're driving down
the road right yep there you go drive
zebra that could be your face I'm
driving down the road and she goes I'm
hot won't we take a dip in there yeah
and he like wants Kenya girl and she
goes listen if you get in that water
I will suck the skin off your stupid
dick and we get out of this water I just
want to get in this water yeah let's do
it when she jumps in and goes Brian come
in I would be garrix wife in the car
seat and what if she said this you know
what again this water
you can go anal yeah and I was in this
water today it was very nice to know you
and is there anything you'd like me to
say to your next of kin I and then she
would die and I would still want to
entice you to go in no no no what if she
said Brian get in and whatever reason
psyche flash from the past and she has a
cell phone she goes I will suck your
dick while you watch gay porn videos
I am no no sir okay that's not Sony of
all right here's one Brian
[ __ ] in the water you're getting
close I mean close Brian get in the
water I will suck your dick
while we watch men compete in CrossFit
and fight videos I will have dance
running Luke Rockhold on loop doing
spinning back-kick knockouts for you
just get in the water every second how
long do I have to be in the water and
have the best cheese you've ever had in
your life on this side of my toe on that
she's gotta get in bro okay but I'm
getting right out I'm getting right
it's a dangerous which is the sharpest
cheddar cheese on one plate look at the
videos of CrossFit dudes on the other
I'm sorry
crocodiles oh my god do their dinosaurs
another dinosaurs they're dinosaurs okay
and that it chin pretty much yeah now
did I lose all my jobs from the spot
really we're both on TV you know what
though we're never gonna do this we as
an nc-17 good babies for our fans good
podcast you tell me a Marilyn Monroe
should entice you into the waters of the
Amazon you went go for it y'all would
maryland's on my age now perrilyn get
out of the water I'm gonna be so mad I
don't know but just people don't get in
the water in Lake Victoria where they
fish and people like the fishermen it's
their life and they get eaten all the
time and then they're like I'm so sad I
lost my arm well yeah and they're just
not the fish we got to get another job
I'm not that I like the the relentless
bro what a relentless you got to do it
inspiring just get in the water and
they're crazy
don't let the alligator win bro crooks
Crocs everywhere Merrill went to Costa
Rica I was just driving my hands along
the Crocs
stupid animals yep it's not a chin
that's it the fun part very fun always a
good time you're back on set tomorrow oh
my god that's Photoshop you're back on
set tomorrow sir so we're gonna do a
podcast Thursday buddy Thursday y'all
thank you for working with me Thursday
I'll see Emma the IMP
of tomorrow night and then I'm at the
economy store Joe Rogan friends
Thursday night I think it sold out
though yes and then our show we're doing
next Thursday sold out sold out in like
30 seconds I know isn't that great
should have done - oh you know speaking
of two shows the second show at the
Orpheum in Phoenix at the justice for
last Comedy Festival with Theo von big
Jay Ari Shaffir Bryan Callen myself they
added a second show at 9:30 now it was
the second show at 9:30 the first show
is all sold out those tickets will go on
sale as I'm speaking they might be on
sale either way I'll post it Bryan a
post-it find kit a post-it stay tuned
because those [ __ ] will go fast as
well good and by the way this Sunday I
am doing I'm gonna be on a show this
Sunday with Whitney Cummings at the
Comedy Store for pancreatic cancer I'm
just doing a charity I'm gonna be on
that so if you're around the Sunday come
on down we're gonna have some very good
comics very good comics I don't work on
Sunday so I think David Spade might even
be there for me well I'm trying to get
him he it depends on if he's busy or not
but we'll have some just put David on
this show that would be great
I'd like to say the best I might need
made or um Bobby Lee there's some people
I forgot about to come on the show
I'm 30th we'll get some surprise guests
the 30th is are sold out it's no I'm
saying it's sold out but ya know I'm
talking about that's what I'm talking
about is this is this Sunday this Sunday
for pink Oh gotcha sorry we shouldn't
really gets paid on the podcast yes well
my faves yeah we shadows nice to me he's
all sake
all right that's it dudes this is the
fine kid we're out